he is PJ Carlesimo how are you coach
excellent rich over you I'm doing fine
what do you think the main headline
other than obviously Virginia wins the
game coming out of the national champ
that game is from last night I just
think great tournament I think it was
one of the most competitive tournaments
we've had I think we had more I mean one
possession overtime buzzer beater games
it was B Rozelle would have been happy I
just think there were more teams had a
chance to win it this year than almost
any year we've seen and this team they
just refuse to lose I mean rich they
dodged bullets left and right in this
tournament they any time they were down
to they had to have the last shot of how
to make a play they were able to do it
so I'm just I'm super impressed I think
it's a it's great i I feel badly for
Texas Tech I to be fair to Virginia even
if all one's had been healthy as
Virginia still could have won to be fair
the Texas Tech could they have won with
the healthy owns yeah maybe but it was
again you need a little bit of luck too
and Virginia had Virginia was great but
they they had their share of luck also
yeah they sure did I mean they looked
dead in the water at times against
obviously Purdue we know what happened
with Auburn and then last night they
were exactly I mean and then last night
down three and Hunter hit that crud that
clutch crucial three and then and then
overtime hit and replay played a role I
hit this at the top I'm a big plate a
major I'm a huge advocate of replay in
the NFL and and the rules that that were
made in the NFL recently for pass
interference now being reviewable even
if it's not called I'm an advocate of
that what I'm not an advocate of is
using replay in instances in just
certain parts of the game but you're not
allowed to look at it at other parts of
the game and that that was a crucial
moment last night where what would have
been off of Virginia and Texas Tech ball
would say eight minutes to go in the
second half or even three minutes to go
in the second half it becomes Virginia's
ball and and that was kind of a turning
point PJ no what are your thoughts it
was a major turning point and again
was a replay that took so long I mean
him they looked at it from so many
different angles and at the end of they
did it right yeah I think they got it
right it looked like it literally at his
fingertip it was it was amazing but it's
hard the thing that bothered me from a
coaching standpoint not not especially
in this torn and I'm just in general
with replay it's taken the element of
saving your time outs like one team
maybe saves time outs the other team
can't and it's not a question of like if
you're a coach you weren't smarter now
sometimes you just gotta use timeouts in
the course of the game to stop runs and
do things like that well now with these
replays in the last two minutes which
you know there's a lot more of them it's
almost like you're not rewarded for the
fact that you didn't have to use your
timeouts and you get these free timeouts
you know like where the guys go over and
huddle with the coach and if anything
there's more timeouts in the game now
because the replays and that's always
bothered me a little bit you you want to
get the calls right but you you've kind
of taken the element of having timeouts
or not having timeouts left at the end
of the game out the window now I know
it's an end and I'm just wondering what
from a coach's perspective would you be
up for because to me that the issue is
also just in equality that that would
have been a certain call at a certain
part of the game outside of two minutes
it shouldn't be that call just because
it's inside two minutes so what about
the idea of giving coaches the the
ability to challenge during a game and
if you're wrong it's a technical
free-throw for the other team I like
that I just think that you need to
balance it right now I do want to get
calls right and we've got technology
that allows us to do that but there's
got to be a limit and I think that what
football does that don't they I mean
that the way we're okay if you think it
was a chat like that one there wouldn't
have been challenge it's a question and
I believe in your kids because so many
times players go hey it was off me or
something like that you got it yes the
trigger kids in those situations so look
don't say something unless you know
you're right but I would like that idea
where the coach has to make a decision
and if it's the right decision good
you're not penalized for it but if
are just stops you from having you know
infinite replays particularly at the end
of the game and plays that are just as
important at other times you know go
unchallenged westwood ones PJ Carlesimo
here on the Rich Eisen show and I said
at the top of the program and on Twitter
yesterday that we we may see a one-seed
lose to a 16 seed again but we will
never see a 1 seed lose to a 16 seed and
then come back the next year and win it
all I'm wondering what you thought of
the coaching job of Tony Bennett to just
keep it all together from it's been a
calendar year journey that that has been
remarkable I wonder what your thoughts
on that would be PJ well it was I don't
I don't think he did a good job I
thought he did a great job but to be
honest with you I like I'm I'm I guess
in disagreement with everybody with the
worst at first Tony didn't do a good job
he did a great job but it reminded me a
little bit remember a couple years ago
and San Antonio got beat in Miami and
that kind of fueled them the next year
pops team and then they came back and
won the championship the next year I
thought that was exactly what we had
here and you know everybody forgets
Hunta didn't play in the game last year
so doesn't take away from what UMBC did
but he didn't play in that game that was
a major factor like Owens playing
impaired last night I'm not surprised
that a number one with as many
underclassmen as Tony had last year
comes back and they went like 60 plus
games in two years so I really am not
surprised and I'm actually a little
surprised that everybody is making such
a big deal out of hey they got beat in
the first round last year too the first
number they're still in number one they
were a number one last year and they're
our number one this year
was virtually the entire team back
including their best player who didn't
play last year number ones are supposed
to win the tournament so I'm not don't
that get me wrong I'm not diminishing at
all what Tony and UVA did but I'm a
little surprised at that narrative to be
honest with you I think from day one we
all said Virginia like if you had to
pick three or four teams I had Gonzaga
and UVA easy for me to say that now but
I said anybody cared about
our interviews in the beginning of the
year everybody thought Virginia had a
chance to win it this year so I'm not
surprised he's not a good coach he's a
great coach
they had this team back it was a
beautiful team and you know one also is
nice rich to see the three and four year
teams when it's nice to see a team that
stays together for a little bit and what
crispy is did with new guys in one year
I had them in the East Regional last
year with Villanova beat them to keep
them from going to the Final Four
he's got to add Mooney and Owens now
obviously they were great great pieces
to add but that's a team that I think no
one expected to be this good this year
he's an unbelievable job also PJ
Carlesimo Westwood one few more minutes
left with him and as he's making his way
out of Minneapolis right now you led me
to my next question here I mean you got
your Roman guy or juniors hunter you
mentioned wasn't there last year this
was his second go around there at
Virginia and then Chris beards Texas
Tech team taking a kid from Italy and
then two transfers two transfers who had
graduated from other programs and Owens
and Mooney and the the freshman Layden
one and done Duke team didn't even make
the final four do you think we are
seeing in a potentially copycat
situation what other schools can do you
mentioned parity have we seen a
watershed moment maybe away from the
one-and-done attempts to win a
championship hmm
I don't think so because I think people
are still going to recruit enough
condition to see what happens with the M
and ba going forward if they pass that
where they can go directly from high
school but I think most people are still
if you have a chance to get a great
player you're gonna take him sometimes
it's like you get surprised last year I
think I'm re Spellman going into the
East region in Boston was probably issue
whether he was going to come out or not
he played so well the last four games he
came out I think even Genzo wasn't
coming out going into the championship
game and he comes out so it's hard to
predict you know what when these guys
are gonna jump so I think people are
still going to recruit the one-and-done
and truth be told rich very easily both
Kentucky and Duke could have been it I
had that divot Kentucky Auburn game for
Westwood and obviously Duke good
easily one in been there we could have
had a Duke Kentucky game I can't
remember no it wouldn't have been
matched up I don't think but I mean we
could have those two in the finals in
the narrative would be a you need one in
John's to win a championship now a day
so I I think it's bet fragile I think
people are going to continue to recruit
so one and Duns because they're just too
good and frankly sometimes you don't
even know they're one and does when you
get him you know he's a very good player
and he has a spectacular year or a great
n-c-double-a and the next thing you know
he's coming out so but I do like the
parody I we all said the beginning of
the year when you're a coach you're a
player we can win it this year you know
that's always the narrative I think
there are more teams now I guarantee you
Tony and his team said that back in
October when they started practice but I
think there were more teams this year
said that and believed it and it was
actually true now our bird to me was a
surprise Bruce Pearl did like not a good
job did a ridiculous job but I think
there were more teams going into this
tournament that look you know could look
in the mirror they were looking at each
other's eye saying hey we're good enough
to win this thing I think that's what
made for such a great tournament I mean
there were so many good basketball games
in this tournament this year
and then there were the controversial
again calls like the one at the end of
all Bern and Virginia and then the one
at the end of Purdue and Tennessee where
a lot of people are wondering how do the
referees not swallow their whistles and
I asked this with ultimate respect PJ
Carlesimo did you at any point in time
just look at these people complaining
about last-second calls by whistles that
should be swallowed and say cry me a
river did you at any point think that in
the back your head well there's nothing
you can do I mean you know the other
thing that people sometimes forget a
little bit the referees that are working
in the tournament of the best ones they
were picked because of you know what
they've done their body of work over
their careers and what they've done
during the year and during the
tournament the best ones advance so it
you can't you really can't complain
about officiating in the NC double-a
tournament you know it's like
complaining about the rest in the NBA
Playoffs only the best drafts is there
and they're you know they're trying the
best they can and you know
I hate it's not Leslie always Holly
apologizes to me Holly general are
majordomo in the beginning every time
because he goes I got asked so we got to
ask you look what happened in the Auburn
game look what happened in this game we
got to ask you about Bill Robinson and
Seton Hall and you know that's always
going to be but you can't change it so
you got to move on and as long as
officials are there those judgments
those calls they got to make it you're
going to get some that people are not
going to like so you think Rick Barnes
and Bruce Pearl are going to be asked
about this thirty years from now - not
as much as we are cuz I was in the
championship game but in in those two
areas absolutely hmm ours is ours is a
little more national because it was the
championship game in their league and
the circles where they are yeah they're
gonna be asking ton there's no question
about that but hopefully it does it
doesn't linger as long gone
well last one for you PJ I want to ask
you about the the Association because
you are well versed in that with your
work with the the worldwide leader in
sports as we are getting set for the
playoffs how real are the Bucks do you
think they can take it down if certainly
the Warriors advance from the West and
they're real they're good enough to win
it I really a lot of what I said more
teams have a chance issue I still think
Golden State's the team to beat but when
you watch the ups and downs they had all
year you I think they're more vulnerable
than than any of the last couple having
said that that's still the team I deal
with if I could only pick one the Bucks
have been the best team in the league
the entire year and they like they
haven't done it with mirrors they've
just humbled a lot of people
the only question and it's a big
question it's a valid question playoff
experience not just being in a playoff
so so so few of them have you know been
in a playoffs but even less has enjoyed
playoff success and that what the
Warriors have done is going to help them
a ton no walk these got their hands full
even coming out of the yeast I do think
they'll do it I do think they're legit
are they good enough to win the whole
thing yes but it's really hard usually
your first time in as a group and you
know all the things that you're going to
have to you need to like to get to we
talked about - Rico ins you
an injury is going to play a big thing
you know Malcolm you just saw what
happened at bucks late in the year so
sometimes health plays a huge factor in
the NBA playoffs but I'm looking forward
to it because I do think the twos in the
West feel whether they're correct or not
they feel Golden State's vulnerable like
they're saying hey we can get them this
year and I think there's an element of
truth to that but the cell I'm
interested in watching the Celtics and
the Warriors because I'm curious whether
their playoff experience and their
playoff success is going to be a bigger
factor and kind of you know help them
put behind and the fact that both of
them had by their standards what kind of
inconsistent regular seasons as you
honest your MVP yes
yeah solely because the first night
obviously is great but you know the
arguments for Harden and whoever else
you want to put in their best player on
the best team to me is always the MVP
unless they don't have a candidate you
know if it's somehow a really balanced
team doesn't have a great player
I've always been I'm old-school he's the
best player on the best team in the
league he should he's the MVP in my mind
it's not even close with all due respect
to what James Harden has done
PJ safe travels always appreciate our
chats let's chat during the NBA playoffs
I'd love to rich thank you very much
great being with you got it's PJ
Carlesimo of Westwood One and ESPN
jetting off from the Final Four for more
of the Rich Eisen show tune - audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV for free on BR
live or download the Rich Eisen show app